eine pandemie ist in etwa so sexy wie
eine steuererklärung
doch in krisenzeiten sehnen sich viele
menschen nach liebe zuneigung und
zärtlichkeit 6 erscheint deswegen gerade
jetzt ein guter ausweg zu sein um für
einen kurzen augenblick entspannung und
glück zu erleben aber so einfach ist es
nicht wir haben uns umgehört wie es um
das liebesleben der deutschen steht
verändert sich nicht wirklich alles wird
er in die gar nicht das gefühl
also ich bin zwar in einem beziehung und
ich kann sagen dass man tatsächlich
sexleben sage ich mal aktiver geworden
ist auf jeden fall denn nun hat
natürlich auch mehr zeit man es öfter zu
hause man kann nicht so viel unternehmen
was ich glaube kinder und und die ganzen
anderen portale die können sich gerade
nicht über mitglieder beschweren aber
was willst du machen ein schnelltest
wenigstens ein bisschen
schon während des ersten lok downs
wurden auf dating apps wie kinder mehr
als doppelt so viele nachrichten
geschickt auch andere plattformen wie
parship oder elitepartner erleben werden
corona einen enormen zulauf
der von havanna
dann schön hat einen hut kriegen muss
kann manches schon auf der strecke
nein bei uns kann ich kann nur sagen da
ist dass wir die kinder und enkel haben
quasi kommen wir nicht so richtig dazu
das ist irgendwie noch schwieriger
geworden werden da sagen wir zu hause
bleiben sollen sich doch auch wissen
warum sie zusammen sind einfach wieder
prioritäten setzt sind trotz pandemie
ist den deutschen die lust wohl nicht
vergangen mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren